Beyonce you always wanted me to be
honest have you gotten to meet her yes I
have at the White House
oh man why don't you why don't you pile
it on a little bit yeah at the White
House we were both wearing suits made of
real gold what was that like it was
amazing like if you know Beyonce is like
my favorite person like I love her right
oh my cute there's nobody No yeah when
you hug over she could probably sense I
sense another favorite right it's okay
Beyonce maybe not just a little bit
above yeah so what was it like when you
met Beyonce were you able to conduct
yourself did you think did you stay cool
about it or Julie oh no like why would I
fake like why would I say cool of
Beyonce like again Marseille you're
talking to me like I'm a child and
you're right I love the dynamic of this
interviewer like were you talking about
Kony so what did you how did you behave
I cried I was yeah I was shaking cuz she
was like in a tent and I was outside and
my mom saw her first and my mom was like
yo
stop everything you have to go get
Marseille so it was really cool and then
jay-z was like right next to her sounds
like jay-z's there too yeah
what and so I bet you're losing it did
you did you lose it as much over jay-z
unfortunately not Beyonce was right here
yeah oh my gosh I love you so much I was
like oh hi I know you love jay-z G what
that must be his life he's like the most
famous person he's one of the most
famous person ever right but then he
marries Beyonce so his whole life is
people like meeting comments and then
[Laughter]
you know they're both they're both like
pretty cool like one of the best Power
couples right now yeah we haven't met my
wife
you